Die Feuerwehr rückt auch bei hohen Temperaturen
zum Löschen aus, zum Löschen von Durst.
Den haben, wie hier in Köln, neben den Menschen,
besonders die Bäume.
Bestimmte Exemplare zu wässern sei bei 35
Grad schlicht eine Notwendigkeit, sagt Peter
Schmidt vom Grünflächenamt der Stadt Köln.
"Straßenbäume, insbesondere im bebauten
urbanen Raum leiden ganz besonders.
Es ist einfach kein Platz, das bisschen Platz,
was da ist, die Erde ist völlig ausgetrocknet,
deswegen ist es ein Segen für die Bäume."
Bei den hohen Temperaturen sei auch den Menschen
angeraten sich "zu wässern".
Abhilfe verschafften aber auch Ventilatoren,
die wie hier in Berlin, derzeit in allen möglichen
Formen, Größen und Funktionsweisen in unterscheidlichen
Preislagen zu haben sind.
"Es ist einfach viel zu heiß bei uns zu hause.
Der ein oder andere ist auch schon umgekippt.
Deswegen muss das auf jeden Fall jetzt mal
sein, sich so ein Ding zu holen."
"Ventilator kaufen, ich glaube, die machen
diesen Sommer ganze Kasse mit diesen Ventitaloren.
Aber trotzdem, ich komme aus Spanien, ich
bin daran gewöhnt."
Andere setzen lieber auf Eis - auch das in
allen möglichen Variationen.
"Eiscapuccino trinken.
Ja, uns sonst, wir genießen es ehrlich gesagt
gerade ein bißchen, die Hitze, so richtig
Sommerfeeling zu haben."
Zum Sommerfeeling gehört für viele auch
ein Gang in die Natur.
Wer einen Spaziergang durch den Wald plant,
der sollte aufpassen.
All zu schnell ist bei den hohen Temperaturen
auch in unseren Breiten ein Waldbrand entfacht,
weiß Britta Lolk, Leiterin der Oberförsterei
Wünsdorf südlich von Berlin.
"Nein, dieses Jahr sind es mehr Brände, wir
haben jetzt schon 222 Brände mit einer Brandfläche
von 336 Hektar.
Wir hatten sonst immer so um die 200, aber
dann die gesamte Waldbrandsaison in einem
durchschnittlichen Jahr.
Letztes Jahr war natürlich ein sehr feuchtes
Jahr, da hatten wir weniger Brände.
Aber es ist abzusehen, dass diese Waldbrandsaison
negative Schlagzeilen mit sich führen wird.
Also, wir haben mehr Brände als sonst."
In diesem Jahr seien im Land Brandenburg besonders
viele Waldbrände zu verzeichnen, 222 allein
bisher, die kritische Zeit sei ja noch nicht
vorbei.
Üblich seien in einer gesamten sogenannten
Waldbrandsaison rund 200 Brände.